a great-grandmother's family is suing
Alaska Airlines after she tumbled down
an escalator in the Portland Oregon
Airport the troubling incident was
caught on video the 75 year old woman in
a wheelchair died three months after the
fall that left her badly injured Adriana
Diaz is here with the allegations and
the airlines response
Adriana good morning good morning the
family of Bernice Kerr Kona hired help
to make sure she arrived safely to her
connecting flight but now they're suing
arguing that the airline and its
contractor did not provide the service
as promised
Bernice Kona was coming home from a
family vacation in Maui she landed in
Portland and the family's attorney says
they requested a wheelchair assistance
service to escort her to a connecting
flight but surveillance video shows her
wandering the terminal alone attorney
Brooke Cunningham she was provided
assistance off the airplane and into her
wheelchair by Alaska's company that they
contract with Huntley and then she was
left there and she became confused and
that led to the fall Gakona appeared to
confuse the escalator for an elevator
she fell down headfirst while others
tried to help her the attorney took
video statements from family members
Kona suffered multiple injuries she was
in constant pain
a wound on her right foot became
infected leading to amputation below the
knee a day after that surgery Kaukauna
died all they needed was somebody to use
the escort service that they're required
by law to provide she would have been
perfectly fine Alaska Airlines said in a
statement it appears that Miska Kona
declined ongoing assistance in the
terminal and decided to proceed on her
own to her connecting flight the airline
also noted her reservation did not note
any cognitive visual or auditory
impairments we reached out for comment
from the wheelchair service contractor
but have not heard back the family's
wrongful deaths complaint does not
specify any monetary damages but it says
Cocoa's medical bills from the fall
totalled nearly $300,000 Dana
Adrianna thank you hard to get those
images out of your mind of her on
as a family and people around trying to
help her